hallo ich bin's ali wer mich kennt dabei
wackelt wenn ich gross nach morattis und
murat große liebe nach sally natürlich
sind sie ließ unwiderstehliche die
nation
19 jahre war ich habe den letzten neun
jahren habe ich 30 kilo zu gelangen
der sonntag wird sich die neue wachs
sendung hat sie nicht von mir einfach
zum dreißigsten september
nur box
[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es von mir ein törtchen eine
zwetschgen tat mit baiser haube
die sieht so aus ich habe hier die
baiser masse einfach als kleine röschen
obendrauf gespritzt und zwetschgen zeit
ist für mich die perfekte backzeit man
kann mit zwetschgen so viel machen
entweder einen ganz normalen
streuselkuchen von blechen mit hefeteig
das finde ich ganz lecker oder auch
buchteln mit zwetschgen also da gibt es
viele neue ideen auch bereits schon auf
meinem kanal für diese version habe ich
jetzt das ganze mit einem betrag
zubereitet mit dinkelmehl und den muss
ich jetzt auch zuerst herstellen für den
mürbeteig verwende ich 75 gramm zucker
eine prise salz 125 gramm kalte butter
den abrieb von einer orange 2 eigelbe
und 250 gramm mehl für den mürbeteig
nehme ich jetzt zuerst einmal den zucker
ihr könnt ihr auch zum beispiel
krokusblüte zucker nehmen oder birken
zucker einfach eine etwas andere
alternative zu normalem zucker dann die
butter ich habe jetzt hier dinkelmehl
ihr könnt aber auch normales weizenmehl
oder auch glutenfreie ist milch
verwenden von bezirks rhein
gemeinsam mit den gelben dann noch eine
orange
da nehme ich natürlich eine unbehandelte
orange ihr könnt auch eine zitrone
nehmen aber orange passt zu zwetschgen
auch sehr gut und da einfach so ein
bisschen was vom april
[Musik]
und jetzt die zutaten kurz zum mürbeteig
verbinden
[Musik]
dix sieht es ein bisschen gruselig aus
aber wenn ich dir jetzt gleich mit den
händen zusammen knetet dann so schön
geschmeidig
[Musik]
durch das ding der meldeliste jetzt auch
ein bisschen dunkler das finde ich auch
richtig schön und jetzt denke ich ihn ab
und stellen für etwa eine stunde in den
kühlschrank
[Musik]
der teig ist es gut durch gekürt und
jetzt kneten einmal noch mal durch damit
euch schön geschmeidig wird
[Musik]
jetzt rollen auf einer bemehlten
arbeitsfläche auf etwa 30 cm durchmesser
aus
durch das dinkelmehl gestellt so ein
bisschen griffiger
aber das ist gar nicht schlimm da seht
ihr einfach dass es so auch gut
funktioniert muss halt nur ein bisschen
vorsichtiger ausrollen
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier schon meine tat form
mit hebe boden
so bekomme ich nämlich die tat später
auch einfach wieder raus der teig ist
jetzt einfach ein bisschen größer als
die tat form kann ich die einsprühen mit
back trance play dann den teig hier
vorsichtig auf rollen wenn der bericht
ist es auch nicht schlimm und stand vorm
damit auskleiden
[Musik]
mit ganz normalem weizen mädels da ist
ja nicht ganz so brüchig und es geht
dann auch ein bisschen geschmeidiger
aber einige fragen halt immer ob man
weizenmehl auch austauschen kann und
deswegen heute einmal mit links
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen wir einfach eine palette
oder ein messer und könnt hier am rand
den teig wegstreichen
mit aus dem übrigen teil könnt ihr zum
beispiel kekse backen oder auch einfach
einfrieren um das nächste mal wieder
eine tat draufpacken
ich werde den tag nicht vor backen
sondern werden gleich mit dem sketch zum
backen weil die auch einfach schön weich
werden soll
und jetzt bestreiten ein bisschen kreis
der krieg sorgt nämlich dafür dass die
flüssigkeit nicht in den teig geht und
dann bleibt einfach die flüssigkeit
obendrauf
und das reicht einfach nicht durch
[Musik]
und die zwetschgen die habe ich jetzt
hier bereits in stein und halbiert die
kommen jetzt hier drauf
dann noch mit zuckersüßen dann nimmt er
einfach zucker nach geschmack
meistens sind am anfang erstmal
säuerlicher und später zur jahreszeit
werden so sei deswegen müsste einfach
selber probieren wie süße das haben wohl
aber ich finde die sollten hier noch ein
bisschen säuerlich bleiben denn da kommt
ja später noch bis oben drauf was hier
noch gut passt ist sind einfach so ein
bisschen verrühren
[Musik]
jetzt kann die tat so schon in den
backofen und nach etwa 10 bis 15 minuten
backzeit werde ich schon die baiser
masse zu bereiten
[Musik]
für die pc masse verwende ich drei
eiweiß eine prise salz 75 gramm zucker
und 75 gramm puderzucker zuerst schlage
ich jetzt das eiweiß mit der prise salz
steif
[Musik]
jetzt ruhig denn zucker langsam dazu und
den puderzucker und rührt die macht
solange ein bisschen steif und glänzend
ist
[Musik]
start ist jetzt richtig schön
vorgebacken hat auch eine tolle farbe
und die bc masse ist jetzt auch soweit
glänzt schön ist steif und daher kann
ich sie jetzt auch gut auf die tat drauf
spritzen fühle ich jetzt einfach in
einen spritzbeutel und da habe ich eine
große stern teile drauf und wenn jetzt
keine spritzbeutel habt und auch keine
spritzt schule könnt ihr die baiser
masse auch einfach mit dem teig schaefer
darüber verteilen
[Musik]
so und jetzt vorsichtig rosen auf
spritzen und zwar am rand anfangen und
die rose aus der mitte heraus als
kringel auf spritzen
[Musik]
und die übrige pc masse könnt ihr
einfach hier aufs blech spritzen und wie
sieht super aus bagdad
[Musik]
jetzt kann die tat noch fertig gebacken
werden
[Musik]
die tat lass dir nach dem backen am
besten komplett abkühlen und könnt ihr
dann mit hilfe des hebels bodens einfach
aus der tat vom herauslösen
erst danach kann sie schon angeschnitten
werden
hört ihr schon die bisher haube
ich halt auch so schneiden können dass
eine rose
letztere halten egal und guck mal wie
saftig
schade schade dass der murat grad nicht
da es zum probieren richtig schade wo
rate ich übernehme seinen job wohl noch
längere
perfekt
vor allem die bcv bist du wirklich drauf
achten beim lagern
der bc dass der tat dass ihr jetzt
keinen deckel drauf macht weil das gerät
an sonst sehr weich wird und wenn ich so
eine tat habe die decke ich dann einfach
mit einem küchentuch ab mit einem
sauberen und dann bleibt die b c haube
auch wirklich schön knackig echt perfekt
und durch das dinkelmehl bekommt die tat
wirklich so einen ganz anderen geschmack
ein bisschen mehr als sonst und ich
finde das rezept solltet ihr mal
ausprobieren nachlesen könnt ihr es auf
sex - blog.de und ich wünsche euch viel
spaß beim nachbacken schicken auf jeden
fall auch ein foto ihrer tat und ich
wünsche euch viel spaß beim backen bis
zum nächsten mal traf er
[Musik]
neu bei gosee ist der größte stern im
bug universum in meiner neuen sendung
verrate ich spinne neue rezepte tipps
und tricks
mit sally wird der sonntag einfach
herzen
einfach sitzen mit sally wird das button
einfach
einfach schnell ab 30 september